it's great to welcome to the program
today Nancy Eisenberg who's the author
of the New York Times bestseller
white trash her new book co-authored
with Andrew Burstein is the problem of
democracy and it will be reviewed in the
New York Times Sunday Book Review this
coming weekend
Nancy great to talk to you well nice to
meet you or at least hear you let's
let's start with the the sort of history
of democracy in the United States
because I think that there is this view
held among many if not all that the sort
of the type of democracy with the
parameters that it has in 2019 is the
obvious result of the range of views
that were held by the founders and
framers of the United States but this is
not true right I mean there was a range
of opinion as to what type of
representative democracy we should have
you're exactly right I mean what we what
we forget is that the government that we
have if we think about the federal
government was set up as a
constitutional republic there's no
mention of democracy in our Federal
Constitution there's no mention of
democracy in our favorite texts the
Declaration of Independence and at the
time of the founding if we think about
from the period of the revolution to the
Constitutional Convention basically
democracy was seen as something that was
best served by Congress Congress was to
be the Democratic branch and there when
we talk about a range of opinions there
were still people who were deeply
concerned about democracy democracy was
associated with the period of the
classics and as john adams said later he
basically would refer to how there was
never a democracy that did not commit
suicide
they were aware that democracy's pure
democracies which we don't have we don't
even have a pure democracy today were
and were historically seen as unstable
governments I think it's important
before we go any further because I know
that there will be people in my audience
who will immediately think of this the
our ways in which pointing out that we
have a constitutional republic is
sometimes used in 2019 or 2018 to
justify voter suppression when there are
people today who are understandably
concerned about some of the voter
suppression tactics and the influence
they have on democracy the term used
colloquially you will see some of the
supporters of those tactics say why are
you talking about democracy we have a
constitutional republic and I would like
now that you're here to tell us why it
is really important to understand that
when people say that they don't mean
that if we have an election it's okay
not to let people vote or not to count
people's votes that we are talking about
a structure of government and it is a
much higher level conversation yeah I
think there are several things to
realize I mean any government it changes
over time I mean right now we're facing
problems that have to do with partisan
gerrymander gerrymandering we have
problems with too much money in
campaigns the idea of the donor class
which is something that the founders
never supported and the other thing you
have to realize is that I disagree with
that we have to understand the real
historical roots of our government
because there has always been voter
suppression I wrote about this in the
context of white trash that during the
period of poll taxes which were not
considered unconstitutional until like
1966 essentially there have always been
efforts to suppress the vote think about
the fact that women were not allowed to
vote until 1920 so we have to realize
that at every stage of our historical
development there have been efforts to
suppress the vote and we haven't just
had this gradual development this
evolution of our government from a
constitutional republic to a more
perfect democracy democracies have have
problems rooted in the rise of parties
which is something else that the
founders did not include in the
Constitution they did they should have
anticipated parties because they existed
in Great Britain but they didn't realize
how much
party development would lead to these
kinds of abuses like voter suppression
my point of mentioning that it's a
constitutional republic is to understand
the actual structure and institution
that we still live in today and to
understand what are the powers of the
different branches of government and for
John Adams the key was that you needed
institutions to check the abuses the
inevitable abuses that all human beings
are prone to he was very aware that
people are prone to abuses that come
from ambition which come from vanity
this is why his major concern of any
kind of elective form of government and
this was true from for even governments
that we think is completely different
from ours even in monarchies for example
he talked about how the people are often
reduced to spectators and they are often
trained and often encouraged to worship
elites and this is even strewed true
today this is why the media is
constantly talking about the cult of
personality which we highlight in our
book because this is a problem that has
to do with voters being and it's even
worse today voters being rooted reduced
to spectators where they simply are
caught up in the excitement the game of
the election caught up in the allure and
the personality of the candidates let's
talk a little bit about the way in which
we can maybe make some good-faith
critiques of some elements of modern
democracy and one of the things I've
always found interesting has been
Plato's view on democracy and when you
look at plato's pseudo skepticism maybe
we could call it or so even even
opposition in some sense to democracy
part of his opposition if I recall
correctly is based on some of the
particular characteristics of Athenian
democracy like the ease with which
people are just executed for example and
it's not so relevant today but one of
the ways that he was concerned about
democracy was the way in which democracy
arguably stands sort of in opposition to
expertise and the idea of
the most informed people making
decisions which of course as we
understand it today we have a crisis of
so-called expertise and the expert
industrial complex and it brings up a
whole other slate of issues if we were
to go in that direction so to step back
from this and take kind of like a 40,000
foot view what are the most important
and relevant critiques of democracy that
you would make in modern day yeah I
think first of all one of the things
that John Adams insisted on you know he
believed that people should not be in
power forever he believed it was very
important even at the level of who we
elect a congress that they needed to be
returned to the people they needed to be
humbled they needed to stay in touch
with the people he also believed
strongly in the importance of the town
meeting and this is actually comparable
to what Jefferson said when he described
war democracy they they both believed
that there needed to be a local
foundation for democracy that the people
actually knew how to effectively
articulate their demands and John Adams
because in Massachusetts they believed
in education which they didn't in
Virginia because they didn't want to pay
for it yes he believed that from infancy
this is what he heard from emphasis at
essentially people needed to learn how
to deliberate debate and articulate
their views and this came from the local
institution of the Town Meeting his son
John Quincy Adams would carry on that
view when he becomes the ardent
defendant defender of the petition and
petitions were the most widespread way
for for everyone in society to
articulate their grievances and in fact
he defended the right of petition it's
not only for for white men but for
slaves for women and even for the you
know the vilified anti-slavery activists
so this is this is one of the essential
ingredients of John and John Quincy
Adams it gets forgotten and it's because
their New Englanders
that they they still kind of fall into
that camp of believing in local politics
and that's essential to democracy the
other issue that I think is relevant
today is the one that I was getting to
is the as we know we have seen our
executive branch become more powerful
this really begins in Eisenhower's error
this is where the right of executive
privilege was first invented we also see
the increasing power of the executive
and foreign policy and one of the things
this is what they were deeply concerned
with because with John Quincy Adams what
he saw emerging around Andrew Jackson
was very much this cult the what we
refer to as the warrior cult of
popularity and the fact that he saw
people being obsequious this is his
words obsequious to executive power and
this is one of the dangers I mean in a
sense it's one of those basic principles
we always go back to but John and John
Quincy Adams believe that you need it
each branch of government to be able to
check the power of other branches of
government because they're all prone to
abuses and so what I mean along those
lines what changes what what are the the
specific changes that could be made in
order to address these issues that have
developed yeah well I think one of the
key issues I've already mentioned is the
problem of regulating the amount of
money that controls politics today we
also need to think about the the
problems that we know we all know about
and many people are writing about right
now is is the damage done through the
internet the way and this is why I
talked about why we have this kind of
virtual cult of personality the fact
that so much of people's information
today comes through the internet the
fact that there's not only do we have
the abuse of elections that can come
through the internet but people in a
sense are fed things that as we know are
untrue are lies this is what John Adams
referred to as quackery and I think this
is the problem and this gets back to
your point that yes we need an educated
citizenry but not just educated in a
sense that it's it's only the college
elites or the professional elites have
to control government it gets back to
this idea of making sure that people
through the town meeting can make their
representatives accountable you remember
remember when several politicians
actually had town meetings who had never
had them before and they suddenly had to
answer questions that the media weren't
asking them yeah and I think this is
this is one of the issues we have to
find a way to address briefly what is
the degree to which the sort of
celebrity worship type culture that we
have today and that in great part is at
least partially responsible for Donald
Trump becoming president of the United
States how much of an issue was that in
the time of the atom's as in earlier
times in the United States sort of
political of infrastructure yeah I know
we considered clearly identified Donald
Trump's rise through his role in reality
TV but it's not new essentially this is
one of the things we highlight I mean
the first time the John Adams sees the
cult of personality takes shape is when
he is in France and watching Benjamin
Franklin turned into the first American
rock star he was adored by the French
people and he played the role he was
always on a stage and he used that as
part of his you know diplomatic
gamesmanship then we have George
Washington you know and this is where
the danger is with the executive branch
because part of where the invented
powers of the executive branch come from
barring from monarchy monarchy borrowing
from the traditions of royalty this is
where executive privilege actually comes
from and in addition to that if one of
the things John Adams said about
Washington is the idea that you know
Washington was successful because of
invented stories of his heroics people
praised his horsemanship
they essentially admired him and as he
said for his handsome face for his
polite bearing and also for his large
estate that they knew he was a wealthy
and they admired him for this so nothing
you there in a sense know nothing new
and then when we get to John Quincy
Adams critique of Andrew Jackson is that
Jackson's identity he's the first to
have a you know campaign biography that
doesn't highlight his statesmanship
because he that's not where he had
really any experience what so long at
all but they turned him into the hero
they turned him into this figure and
even though people knew about Jackson
they knew he was imperious they knew
that his he wasn't that well educated
they in a sense tried to invent this
very popular image for Andrew Jackson
that was used to sort of again celebrate
his personality Jackson as a person not
as someone who deserved to be in such a
high important office of the presidency
and that's where the danger lies we
still live in a society where people
vote based on whether they like the
candidate they vote on whether they
think the candidate likes them and they
assume which is usually incorrect
because TV doesn't tell you the truth
they assume they know a candidate
because they've listened to them talk
and they somehow assume that they're up
close and personal which is what TV
gives you the false sense of but in fact
they're responding to all the wrong cues
and the media contributes to this
because the media is obsessed with you
know getting the sound bites showing the
candidates face and responses and never
really focusing on what's most important
which is none of the issues but right
now we need to focus on how we have to
give a civics lesson to Americans about
how the government really functions what
are the real duties of Congress what is
the role of the Supreme Court what are
the limitations on the executive branch
we really need to kind of remind people
and keep people up to date on what the
real roles of government are as a way to
make sure that they don't sort of
imagine just because a candidate says
something that it's true no question
about that we've been speaking with
Nancy Eisenberg she is co-author of the
new book the problem of democracy with
Andrew Burstein the book will be
reviewed in the New York Times Sunday
Book Review this coming weekend Nancy
really a pleasure having you on well
thanks for having me